pues es importante tener en cuenta a la
hora de explicar este caso que el
expresidente Donald Trump no ha sido el
único líder de estado que se ha llevado
documentos confidenciales desde la Casa
Blanca a su residencias Después de
terminar sus administraciones los
republicanos simpatizantes de Donald
Trump en varias veces han criticado que
algo similar hizo Barak Obama que
también Algo similar hizo hillary
Clinton pero lo que no se cuenta son las
diferencias en los casos de otros
mandatarios al caso de el expresidente
Donald Trump y la diferencia está en que
por ejemplo en el caso de Joe biden
Cuando se le solicitó cuando archivos
nacionales le solicita que devuelva la
información
abre las puertas de su casa entrega la
información que se le está pidiendo y se
evita problemas legales lo que ocurrió
en el caso de Donald Trump es que
archivos nacionales hace más de un año
empezó a pedirle documentos confi que
que no tenía que se había llevado de la
Casa Blanca el ex presidente Donald
Trump su mansión en la Florida se empezó
a pedirse a pedírselo por vías legales
archivos nacionales no recibió la
información que se le solicitó al
expresidente Donald Trump archivos
nacionales acude Entonces al
departamento de Justicia al al FBI y el
FBI entonces en agosto pasado recordemos
pues hace la redada en mara lago Que
obviamente generó muchos titulares
porque era la primera vez que esto
ocurría a una a una residencia y un
expresidente y a pesar de la redada a
pesar de que a la fuerza tuvo que entrar
el departamento de justicia a través del
FBI a rescatar estos documentos
confidenciales el expresidente siguió
mintiendo siguió supuestamente mintiendo
de que ya había entregado todo cuando
Todavía tenía documentos y se siguieron
conociendo vídeos y pruebas de que el
expresidente seguía escondiendo y no se
no estaba devolviendo la información que
ya el departamento de Justicia le había
pedido solamente a través de opinas Es
decir de solicitudes legales sino a
través de muchos otros medios el
expresidente Trump Entonces no no
devuelve esta información y ahí viene
entonces la acusación que se le hace
formalmente en la corte Federal de del
sur de la Florida en este caso ya en
Miami concretamente y es por eso es que
el presidente tiene que responder a
estos cargos criminales federales es el
primer presidente en la historia de
Estados Unidos en tener que afrontar
cargos federales
en este caso en el sur de la Florida
pero a nivel Federal precisamente porque
se tratan de documentos que pues te
afectan la seguridad del país y
precisamente en ese caso pues estos
documentos confidenciales son de siete
agencias de inteligencias diferentes y
tienen información confidencial que van
desde temas nucleares hasta estrategias
de guerras estrategias militares
diseñadas por altos mandos del pentágono
que fueron entre en su momento a la
administración de Donald Trump y que
este se llevó en lo que dicen los medios
nacionales es que concretamente Kelly
que eran entonces jefe militar del jefe
del Comando militar de Estados Unidos
había supuestamente entregado una
estrategia militar contra Irán una
estrategia de ataque militar contra Irán
que el expresidente
se había llevado a Mara lago y en
maralago había había administrado de una
forma bastante mala como lo dice el como
lo dicen las pruebas iniciales que tiene
la la justicia estadounidense
precisamente para inculpar al
expresidente Donald Trump de que se
movieron varias veces estas cajas de que
posiblemente muchas otras personas que
no tenían el visto bueno legal y el
visto bueno de seguridad pudieron haber
accedido a esta información y pues se
pone en riesgo obviamente la seguridad
de el país dado que en la administración
de estas cajas en el transporte de estas
cajas del baño de una bodega de otros
lugares públicos en
algo que recordemos para el agua además
de ser la residencia del expresidente
Donald Trump pues es un Club Social si
han eh los medios nacionales nacionales
acá en Estados Unidos reportaban que
desde que Donald Trump se fue de la Casa
Blanca cerca de 150 eventos sociales se
han hecho en esa en esa residencia en
ese club y esto Pues expone a que esos
papeles esta información confidencial y
esa información que que que es de
seguridad Nacional de Estados Unidos
haya podido llegar a manos de personas
que que no sabemos qué intereses tengan
privados o incluso en contra de Estados
Unidos